as promised he leads the Rams the
high-flying Rams offense right now on
most Sundays and Thursdays and Monday
nights this guy is a a number one
receiver out here in Los Angeles with
all due respect to his teammates were
working like crazy to keep this one seed
right where it is in their back pocket
as they are gonna be on Sunday Night
Football next to two weeks in Chicago
this coming Sunday and then right back
here in Los Angeles against the Eagles
for week 15 he is Robert woods of the
Los Angeles Rams how are you Robert
you bet first things first life life
stuff is everything all right with your
house and you know anybody that's still
out of houses and stuff like that up
there with you yeah yeah able to make it
make it back to the house didn't have to
evacuate but uh yeah you know it was it
was it was crazy a couple of weeks you
know guys being at this place with my
home us you know relocating and no not
no one was going on with the fire but
this portion and you know you know our
guys were able to be safe in their homes
were able to be safe and of course fire
then and all we were hearing is how the
Rams to the front office and management
we're just telling everybody just save
the receipts we got your back with
whatever you need to do with your houses
and what you were staying with what was
that like for you Robert having been in
the NFL as long as you've been in it
yeah I mean they did an amazing job in
in the casing was all this going on
throughout the night you know some guys
being displaced you know a 6:00 p.m. I
extra practice and some guys have to
evacuate at 2:00 a.m. we got the team
did a great job you know fine and find
the hotels in the middle of the night
for guys and their family and just just
taking care of their food and food and
say just making sure the team was
comfortable and just as their
organization have an impact like that
off the field just with life exactly
what you say was very very huge and then
what was it like that Monday night game
with all the first responders and those
who were part of the shooting in
Thousand Oaks being there for that big
game that night Robert it was big you
know just you just felt the energy with
everything going on
shooting the bar shooting but just just
being able to come in la put on a show
like that for everybody just just who
had a rough - we graph ma just for them
to have an experience to get away and
escape and see almost one of the
greatest games of all time that was
amazing man and what was it like playing
in that one Robert exhausting no just
this tick took everything but um just
just a back and forth football game very
fun to watch fun to be in and of course
when the win home yeah I know I mean in
terms of exhausting I mean what was it
particularly exhausting about that as
opposed to other games obviously the
score was one thing but but what was
particularly exhausting that night the
score the yard literally just just back
and forth taking the field having an
having a real shootout you know so you
know 10 14 points and then they're
bouncing right back and this is a
consistent battles throughout you know
literally playing you know all 60
minutes of the game Robert Woods of the
Rams right here on the Rich Eisen show
what is it like getting the offense
handed to you the install like because
we're looking at this and we're seeing
the scheme and we're talking about it
all the time about Shawn McVeigh and the
rest of the offensive staff and how this
is a copycat league and everyone's been
copycat in you that's for darn sure what
is it like for you as a player to
receive these this information week
after week school just coming in coming
in to work out on Mondays and then
seeing that I was gonna attack on
seeming very stratum that's installing
new plays and then you you turn on the
families and the other teams trying to
copy and kind of duplicate and they try
but they can't you know just just for us
to be a top offense with a creative
coach it's finding ways to you know
create plays and create offenses I think
it's great for his mastermind and you
see how how genius it is people are
eternal maka well give me an example of
his genius that you're sitting there and
maybe you're getting a wrinkle thrown
your way at your particular position
on the field you're like I never thought
of that the routes he's literally I feel
like these criminals and finding gaps
are just finding away and getting that
gap at a right time these aren't like
the the normal standard routes like a
slant go leave this find a ways to to
find boys in a defense and and pick them
apart and now here comes a team on your
docket that you want to talk about
copycat I mean they've got speed all
over the place they've got a young
quarterback on his first contract
slinging it around I mean the Bears are
who we think they are which is kind of
in the mold of you guys what's the
biggest challenge for you this weekend
going against an opportunistic defense
Robert yeah just play our game we know
they they know how to get the ball out
they know how to force turnovers but
just just continue to play our game
protect the ball and just execute our
game plan we've been we've been playing
well we've been good enough and we don't
have to start do anything extra or more
to beat the bear with just uh just stay
our games there of course you know it's
gonna be another battle that's their
place but it's gonna be fun but just
display our game and we stick em on
Victoria well the the sense from the
national media at least from this desk
and from others that that I'm familiar
with as well the suggestion is the Rams
better keep winning because you don't
wanna go back to New Orleans and see the
Saints in their building again would you
agree with that assessment that doesn't
matter we haven't even thought that far
far down but really just just trying to
go out and beat the Bears and when
taking one game at a time we know all
the opportunities that are in front of
us but you know we can't get there
without hands this week first and you
know look Robert I mean as I mentioned
you this offense is being copied
throughout the league you could see it
you could see teams that are gonna be
next combine trying to build a team just
like the one that you're you're helping
to such great heights and yet I'll be
honest I don't hear the name Robert
woods up there with names like Antonio
Brown or Julio Jones etc and so on and
so forth how does that hit you
not yet just I feel I could just just
keep climbing and putting in the work I
feel like just finally having an
opportunity to get the ball on my hands
and make those type of plays like those
guys but uh you know just just keep
building and keep work and keep stacking
I know that's always gonna come and it's
coming right now
all right serve some quick hitters with
you Robert woods or the Los Angeles Rams
who's the fastest RAM on the team
fastest either cooks girly-girly huh you
put Gurley in the cooks class huh I do I
do when you get him an open field he's
opened up that style he go as you can
see sometimes this year and even last
year its versatility
although the it seems the only thing
that stops him is is himself at the goal
line with less than three minutes to go
Robert yeah that's how we like it you
know let him keep wanting to keep
pounding and driving the ball down there
and see if he he turns down the goal
line at the 200 points later you turn
down the touchdown - Robert would you do
that yeah yeah okay just checking on
that who's the strongest RAM scaring
Donald you didn't stutter no what's it
like being that guy's teammate there's a
lot of MVP talk for him as in the the
whole shooting match the whole league
not Defensive Player of the Year
yeah just happy he's on our team do you
see him coming to work every single day
and then you see the plays that he makes
similar to one of that practice but his
stress on offerings is I crazy deceased
funny that's how how quick he does it
the moves and he's literally you know
does that he could cause the disaster -
offensive play really quick okay and
last one for you Robert here before I
let you go Kliff Kingsbury was just
hired as the offensive coordinator your
alma mater and I guess co-tenant there
at the at the Coliseum what do you think
of that maneuver
I like it you mean the offense of my you
know what I think it you'll see I think
our power offers to have the recruits
that has a player as always have um and
just just finding ways I think even
similar to here you know you in Buffalo
you know you have the players you have a
talent and soul we have a players you
have a talent but you could have coach
with it who finds ways to be creative
and just find ways to get his guys a
ball I think that would be good for USC
and hopefully you know we turn this
thing around and get back to what we
need to be Robert thanks for the time I
know you've got to go back to meetings
and get ready for the Bears and then the
Eagles and then so on and so forth we'll
chat soon all right thank you bet you
bet that's Robert Woods of the Los
Angeles Rams the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience